hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game that was just played in the
TCC super final season 17 the top chess
engine competition it's stockfish with
the white pieces against Lille at just
zero and as usual in a super final they
go head to head a hundred games first
stock which has the white pieces in a
certain opening in a certain line then
we repeat that exact same line and
opening with Leela having the the white
pieces so this is a really an incredible
game through like really a barbarian
style game so I hope you enjoy it and
let's dive straight into it stockfish
with the white pieces opens with E 4 and
I will mention at at which point they
start using their own moves
so c5 the Sicilian defense Knight f3 we
have e 6 d 4 C characters Knight
captures in the knight to f6 with Knight
to c3 and a6 now the same inning
variation is on the board
sorry not a6 first d6 was played not a6
and only after g4 are still the same
inning g4 and now a 6 so this is the
variation and now they go into their own
moves
so stockfish continues with g5 further
advances the pawn kicks back the night
and 97 by leela and now their
disposition has been reached by human
players plenty of times and a lot of
moves were played here but the move
stalkerish plays the move a3 has never
been played before here at least not in
in top-tier tournaments so it is as a
remove 8 that we have a completely new
game Knight to c6 by Leela continuing
development Bishop to e3 they are
developing and defending with Knight d5
shifting the Knights to sorry that's not
a denied an ID e5 shifting the knight to
a more central square and now Bishop to
e2 again I just developing Knight
captures on d4 trading off a pair of
Knights Queen captures in mount night
back to c6 pushing the Queen back we
have Queen to d2 by stockfish and the
best of the e7 putting pressure under
under g5 pawn h4 further defending it
and now b5 Lewis starts expanding on the
Queen side with h5 continue
to put the points even further on the
Kings side and now Queen to a5 a usual
move in the Sicilian when you're pinning
this night and or if the knight moves
you can offer
there may be a queen trade h6 by
stockfish and now g6 seems like stock we
sure learned a lot from from its match
against alpha 0 we have castles by white
now that all of the points have been
pushed here and it seems like it could
be a bit dangerous because the pawns in
front of the King are so far advanced
but in engine chess the engines really
just don't care
Oliva also castles here and we have f4
just further advancing and just let's
see what happens so the Queen is no
longer needed on a5 Queen back to c7 and
now rook to f2 stockfish prepares rook a
to f1 to double up on the F file he
wants to play Bishop to g4 and then bust
open the position with f5 we have rook
to b8 preparing before and now rook a to
f1 just continuing with the plan Bishop
to d7 continuing development and now
Bishop to g4 we have rugby to c8 now and
Bishop to h3 if this was a human game I
would say Bishop to h3 is a waiting move
waiting to see what the world black will
play but here I have no idea what it
does perhaps if the G file somehow opens
up you want to have maybe the G file
ready for it for your rooks but other
than that I have no good explanation for
for Bishop to h3 now but okay if any of
you guys have an idea
do share in the comments so Queen the b7
bye Leela
again a Reema NuvaRing preparing before
and now Knight the a to a waiting for
for before to be pushed so the the night
also guards it with the Queen and here
we have a 5 now Leah further prepares
before and now Knight back to c3 and
here we have rook to b8 and now b4
bye-bye white not allowing back to put
before with a capture some before 8
captures and now rook F the c8 still
offering the the be for pawn but if
characters then work to be won and you
could you could have some problems here
not
well white will most likely regain the
pawn and not much not much to do
therefore black for black
so instead Lila goes look after c8
before deciding whether to capture or
not and now f5 by stock fish and it's a
really powerful push you don't really
gain anything we're capturing you don't
want to open up the G file if captures
by the e pawn then you can go Knight d5
because you no longer have a control
over the d5 square which is really
important in the Sicilian and after
Bishop to e6 you will get e captures and
f5 captures and d5 characters here and
now again you are about to get crushed
if you allow this then the rooks and the
Queen pile up on the f7 pawn so you
might try and trade Queens here but it
will not be enough because after
characters captures white just captures
here and now this is a threat you also
opened up and attack towards the rook
and blacks position is falling apart so
after f5 lela goes in Knights to e5
instead but still F captures and g6 with
F captors and g6 and now Bishop to F for
preparing Queen d4 to pile up on the
knight on d5 rook to f8 are preparing to
counter double rooks and the F file and
now Queen to d4 with with the idea of
characters and captures we have Queen to
c7 now adding another defender to the e5
square but now comes a beautiful
beautiful move by starfish Knight to d5
again another signature pretty much
Sicilian move 95 this beautiful
sacrifice and it's not easy to decline
this sacrifice because if the Queen
doesn't help the pawn Gardea 5 square
for example if you move the Queen then
it just captures captures and captures
and there is no way to stop mate well
there is but you will suffer severe
material loss take and try and defend
this mate and eventually you will again
get to made it so after 95 we have each
captures on d5 now the this diagonal
opens up still ok now that I see this
position the bishop might be better on
h3 as the night when it comes to e5
attacks the g4 squares so maybe this
Bishop to h3 was an improvement in the
position before starting this whole
madness
probably but okay Bishop character son
b7 we have twin capture son d7 and now
Bush we have Queen captures on d5 with
check now if you go King to h8 then the
ship captures any five check wins the
game you can actually capture because
you lose the Queen and you can just
start giving up material there's about
six captures captures and after you
capture you are just up a whole rook and
black it does not have perpetual check
because you can easily escape here Queen
checking III Queen h3 check now you just
block and next movie stroke f8 and game
over so after Queen d5 check Leela does
the only thing possible that is Knights
to f7 save your piece keep an extra
piece and hopefully avoid checkmate but
now a stock fish goes Queen before again
threatens checkmate and there is not
much to be done here so what can Lila
play well there is a defense however if
you try the the same old 95 it again
runs into the same idea of Bishop
captures on e5 and now again there's not
much to do you cannot capture because of
Queen captures and queen g4 check again
you don't have any perpetual because
after King eight one Queen h3 you just
bring back the bishop and that's it
there is no defense against maid you'd
have to give up your queen characters
captors and captures with check again
threatening mate black would have to go
back not there obviously rook to have
seven to defend mate but still the game
is lost for black Queen and Bishop
against two rooks and Bishop with the
white white pawn so far advanced it
would be a much easier game for white so
after Queen to b4 Bishop to f6 Lila
gives back the piece in order to when
the knight moves the Queen guards the g7
square so white will not be able to
deliver mate so Queen captures on f6 now
comes Knight to e5 now the Queen defends
against mate but now just the Queen g7
check a stock fish calculates precisely
we have Queen captures pawn captures now
attacking here problem is if you capture
with the King King chapter sin g7 then
you get Bishop captures on e5 with check
and after captures the the trades are in
favor of white captures you will just
capture capture
and this is now a winning endgame for
white so remember that because it might
come in handy in the future
so after HP after sin g7 rook F the e it
was played avoiding this trade but now
comes Bishop characters on e5 again and
now again you have to decide whether you
want to capture with the pointer with
the rook the problem with capturing with
the rook is that it just rook to f8
check is very problematic now you will
either capture the pawn and lose a whole
rook or you will capture the rook and
now white brings a queen in her game and
delivers checkmate so instead after
Bishop captures pawn captures was played
but now feel free to pause the video and
try to finish this game with white while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on paying attention as
we are about to enter the position that
we've already discussed and for those
who just want to enjoy the show its rook
to f8 check and the King and pawn in
game is winning rook captures was played
we have root characters on f8 with check
rook captures pawn captures Queen with
check King captures and now King to f1
and at the point is this this King
opponent game is winning for white since
the white pawn is controlling both of
blacks pawns and white will always have
this c4 move followed by advancing the
b-pawn so the game continued king of 7
we have Kingi to end now King back to f8
but just to show you what happens if you
if you create a passed pawn of your own
let's say h5g chapters and now King g8
with the idea of pushing this point
doesn't really work because c4 and after
B captures a b5 and now the at this
point is no not as nearly as close as it
should be to be a factor in the game the
white king can easily stop the C pawn
and the black King cannot help against
both the H point and the beep on so this
would be winning for white so after King
e2 we have King back to f8 but now see
for B capture Sun C for end King D 2 we
have King to g7 again repeating but King
to e7 doesn't doesn't really do anything
if King c3 then King b6 King captures
and now you're just gonna push this pawn
let's say to b7 the
we'll have to go after it and then the
white king just picks up all of these
points and wins the game easily so after
king d2 King g7 was played by Leela
but now b5 with King to f8 now ela just
starts playing some moves as his engines
usually do with b7 King - EI tweive King
to c3 still waiting with the promotion
King g7 be it Queen now h6 was played
captures and the now king of 7 with h7
g5 now and h8 Queen we have king te 6
and Queen B captures on e5 and it was in
this position that allele at just 0
resigned the game and what a victory for
stockfish so it begs the question is a
did stockfish do something remarkable
here this is only game 3 of their 100
game match first two games were drawn
now either this is a starfish brilliancy
we're gonna see that depends on how
Leela wood will deal with the white
pieces in this is that exact same
opening they're already playing it and I
already checked it out it's really a
wild game so anything could happen there
whether we're gonna see either you know
it was a stock rich brilliancy or this
or this line this particular line is
busted and the white should always gain
a huge advantage from the opening as it
allows for some brilliant brilliant
tactical play but we'll see will Lila
equalize with the white pieces or will
stock fish taking the lead very early on
in the match so that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it another engine game
well standard engine versus neural-net
so i do hope you enjoyed it i would like
to thank our always for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Morphy
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world such as the top chess
engine competition so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day